moi c'est l'info quand allez vous
pourrez écouter il faut qu'on parle d'un
truc intéressant c'est le télétravail
avec ce nouveau confinement c'est
l'arrivée évidemment une nouvelle fois
de beaucoup de télétravail et de
vidéoconférence et ça me termine je
trouve ça fascinant de travailler tout
en étant entouré de trop de trucs qui te
divertissent et qui te font plus envie
que ton cours quand est en cours et est
en cours d un bureau un stylo et en
vient carrément à apprendre à faire des
tricks shop et ton stylo tellement c'est
dur de se divertir si t'es pas pris part
le court et le mieux c'est d'écouter le
court évidemment mais tu peux pas à
l'écouté toute l'année nous ne sommes
pas impossible même les projets de la
classe non pas ça c'est impossible mais
là tu es chez toi c'est pas un stylo
qu'il ya à côté de toi c'est ton
téléphone
je vais faire tomber toute la youtube
monnaie je prépare une blague elle est
très longue et arrive mais c'est aps
quatre qu'il ya à côté de toi et pour
couronner le tout j'ai découvert qu'il
ya pas mal de cours en fait les élèves
sont pas obligés de mettre leurs webcams
ce qui est pour moi l'équivalent de
mettre un mépris vantail en cours mais
qui atteint maintenant gens ça fait
genre qui étaient là mais on n'était pas
là ils peuvent totalement se muter en
douce via un bouton sur leurs micros et
ça fait comme s'il était là alors qu'ils
font totalement autre chose et j'ai
l'impression dites moi si je me trompe
que beaucoup de gens ne s'en sont pas
privés de ce petit pouvoir mais des fois
ça a mal tourné et ça a donné lieu à des
moments un croit il ya bref aujourd'hui
on va parler des galères des
vidéoconférences que c'est un truc un
peu inédit en fait dans notre histoire
de faire des cours à distance à un si
jeune âge
à tel point que je suis un peu jaloux
j'aurais aimé en vivre 3 4 des cours
comme ça à l'époque où j'étais au lycée
si j'avais été à la fac c'est marrant ça
me fait rire c'est sympa bref déjà la
vidéo qui m'a donné envie de faire cette
vidéo elle s'appelle pedro sebastian là
l'espagnol est levé de soleil pour vous
c'est un gars sa webcam s'est activée
pendant qu'il était au maximum
jarry et los tres puntos à la mi-mars à
la géniale les gars le gars et a mis son
réveil 20 secondes avant le court il a
le record du monde du réveil le plus
proche du début du cours la réaction du
prof elle est trop cool genre ça le fait
rire parce qu'apparemment il ya un petit
passif avec sebastian genre sebastian
ces voix là il a l'air d'être souvent au
dernier rang tête un peu le gard tête en
l'air et il est même en vidéoconférence
braves à ce que bastien
j'adore la réaction de sebastian c'est
celle de
de ne rien dire de faire comme si ce
n'était pas arrivé le déni le déni le
plus total et d'aller l'élément
sébastien il ressemble à sébastien on
est d'accord tu vis de marché hispanique
avec tes vidéos
du coup tu ne comprends pas ouah ça
ressemble à ça vraiment je découvre ce
truc d'élèves en vidéoconférence c'est
incroyable apparemment lassé les élèves
qui se sont amusés à faire semblant de
se prêter un stylo j'adore ce truc de
complicité entre des élèves et un proche
trouve ça hyper touchant bon à la blague
la blague est pas mal mais un peu vu en
revue bon je vais pas faire le mieux
qu'on est arrivé il ya trop de vidéos
comme ça il ya des preuves qu'ils
reçoivent des cadeaux jour de leur
anniversaire de leurs élèves et il se
met à pleurer ils sont trop touché et
tout et je pleure avec eux ça me touche
voilà l'un de mes élèves c'est renommée
henry connecting trois petits points
pour éviter leur de cours frérot on y
croit jusqu'à ce qu' il ya le petit
icône de micro buts et tu nous prends
pour des cons à il s'agit d'un
professeur il les a mis toutes les
douilles au professeur avant de lui même
devenir professeur aura pas un vrai
héros par contre ce que tu auras c'est
ton exploit sur un portrait dit à 211
ville avance un faux kidnapping pour se
barrer du court attendez vous êtes
sérieux là c'est le coup à faire
vraiment bas d un prof ça en plus pas
gentil
vous
[ __ ] mais c'est quoi tous ces profils
sont incroyables c'est des profs qui
donne envie de devenir prof
c'était impressionnant lui il joue un
guerrier tank dingo je le sens il part
en raid régulière ça ressorti que je
voulais partager a créé le genre de mot
ça devient vite ils ces vidéos aulas l'a
en tout cas les kidnappeurs en short pas
mal alors comment grignoter en placo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais les gars s'amusent à gaver convoi
de ça déjà
j'ai jamais vu une classe où tout le
monde est ami déjà pour commencer et il
prépare des petits happenings à leur
prof c'est fou c'est là probablement
drôle enlevé la lapébie mesure 35
secondes du choc la prof
elle doit à garder son rôle de prof mais
au fond cette anecdote est mal raconté
pendant un siècle on a tout synchroniser
nos écrans avec le logo dvd logo dvd qui
tapait dans les coins de l'écran vous
vous souvenez évidemment mec mais
comment ils ont fait ils ont utilisé un
plugin pour que toutes leurs vidéos ne
forment qu'une grande vidéo en 16/9
c'est [ __ ] geek dans cette classe
c'est les mêmes qu'avant en ont pas
marre madame des quelque chose prenez
deux trois carnets émettait de trois
heures de colle aux médias ils ont plus
bosser pour cette blague que de tout
leur année scolaire je suis
impressionnée elle devrait leur ajouter
tous un point de moyenne générale
franchement ils ont fait un truc faut
pas renoncer le même gars que la vidéo
d'avant ça veut dire ils passent ils
peuvent amener à faire des happenings à
cette dame elle a la meilleure vie
j'adorerais une élève qui se plaint
alors qu'elle n'est pas en mi août
ça met très mal à l'aise disparition
olala est si ça m'arrive s'il vous plaît
faites moi disparaître de la surface de
la terre faites moi réapparaître dans
trois quatre ans mais pas avant au maire
de quelle erreur mon gars tu dois sentir
redevable envers ce prof jusqu'à la fin
des temps même quand tu es plus à la fac
tu prend des nouvelle de lui dans
l'espoir qu'un jour ils te pardonne je
suis bouche bée
comme l eau mon patron coincé en patates
veut qu'on le prenne au sérieux ces
dégâts qui activent une option un peu
drôle surtout mais ils n'arrivent pas à
la retirer
et du coup ils font tous le collègue
c'est pourquoi il coupa sa caméra même
de vous faire genre que tu as km marche
pas que de parler aux gens quand tu es
une pomme de terre
qu'est ce qui t'a pris après il lui
jette la pierre c'est un peu le bordel
dans ce cola attend y en a une qui au
milieu de plein de gens qui dansent il y
en a une qui est devant une galaxie bon
frère il allait lui l'ambassade s'est
pas non plus déconner c'est trop cool
quand des gars ou une position très haut
placées tout qu'on s'attend à un
comportement très sérieux très tactique
et qui font tout l'inversé
j'adore georges pas tu vas dans un resto
gastronomique hyper classe luxe cher et
il va en claquettes short je suis trop
fan de ça bref
en vrai de vrai ça c'est vraiment ce que
j'en ferais si c'était en 2005
le truc de la photo yasad en plein film
d'ailleurs d'agent secret des années
2000 ou devant la caméra sécurité près
d'une photo et la mettre devant la
caméra comme ça aujourd'hui tu as des
webcams virtuel c'est à dire tu simule
une webcam et tu es ce que tu me dis lui
que sa blague aurait cartonné en 2007
mais là c'est charles
aujourd'hui j'ai atteint un nouveau
niveau de perfection du travail à
distance
[Musique]
ben ça j'aime bien je réussis à ce que
j'avais dit elle manque de respect face
aux vidéos qu'on regarde aujourd'hui ça
fait partie du truc où j'aurais aimé
avoir l'idée avant de voir que quelqu'un
a eu l'idée ou est-ce que je suis un peu
jaloux pour halloween papa a créé un
costume de tueurs de meetings zoom zoom
qu'un logiciel évidemment de
vidéoconférence je n'ai pas dit alors sa
creative director elle parle du costume
on dirait part du film avengers lé gars
qu'il faut halloween redescendre un peu
là sa source et moi le meilleur côté
journée là en vrai le costume est
vraiment bien en vrai c'est abusé et le
dédain qui est dingue il a mis une
petite caméra à l'avant avec une
retransmission en direct ici c'est
vraiment bien trouver je trouve avec
marc et une prochaine victime
ah c'est trop fort il ya un côté un peu
mal foch tout ça vraiment bien trouver
bravo pourquoi est-on interview bravo
gré un gars était chez le dentiste dans
ma classe aujourd'hui l'huile afin
d'agréger sens que si on adopte mais les
gars comment fait on met de vos caméras
sans faire exprès il ya peut-être un
truc que j'ai niort mais tu as forcément
appui moi j'ai un pigeon qui font exprès
un peu pour faire rire pour détendre
pour voir si c'est une ou deux fois tu
te rends pas une punition par contre tu
fais rire toute la classe c des héros il
se sacrifie pour la patrie pour divertir
leurs camarades
la vidéoconférence maudite c'est
dégueulasse c'est un très bon moyen de
se divertir en attendant que le prof
arrive ou que le maître de la réunion
arrive
franchement la prochaine fois que je
fais une réunion à 9 comme ça je crois
je demande à tout le monde qu'on essaye
de perdre des amis en ce jour là mais
mais je pourrais dire que je les fais
est-ce que je peux aller aux toilettes
[Musique]
il est trop mignon
il a deux soeurs j'adore vraiment ces
vidéos là parce que ce truc là de
vidéoconférence a vraiment surpris tout
le monde et les professeurs aussi en
fait en vrai et ça les a vachement
stressé puisque la plupart des
professeurs ils prennent leur rôle
vachement à coeur tu vois ils ont
vraiment envie d'aider des élèves de les
tirer vers le haut de leur faire
comprendre un truc sur la vie les aider
dans leur scolarité et là d'un coup on
leur dit bah voilà votre quotidien il va
complètement changer tout va
complètement changer c'est archi
chamboulant je pense quand tes profs et
qu'on me dit du jour au lendemain il ya
plus de salles de classe et chats ou tu
fais tout en ligne tout ça trop tout
changeait pas le comportement des profs
dans ces vidéos l'agent vraiment ils
sont vraiment touchantes ou pas comme
madame bolatti la prof de français qui
m'a mis une heure de colle en sixième
[Musique]
homme
messieurs dames
pour votre sécurité on va établir des
règles d'accord pour que ça vous arrive
déjà de branchies pas la webcam votre
ordinateur si la vidéo n'est pas obligé
vous la branchez pas comme ça il n'y a
pas de j'active où certains experts
ensuite quand vous muté pour quoi que ce
soit visible parce que quelqu'un on se
doute que vous êtes en train ter
n'importe quoi fait le via le
gestionnaire de périphériques ou 12
pouces assez invisible mais qu'est ce
qui est en train de faire je suis en
train de vous donner des conseils pour
mais oublié je suis le pire que je vous
dis la vérité j'ai envie de faire un
cours en ligne en tant que élèves
je serai en vie de taille avec des
élèves là et d'écouté à prof parler je
vous jure je suis deg d'avoir jamais eu
de cours en ligne c'est trop marrant ça
dégage un truc trop cool
j'adore bon je faisais pas mater cette
vidéo pendant un cours en ligne y passer
une excellente soirée journée tout ça
bref on se retrouve très vite une bonne
chose
[Musique]